The David Pakman Show is a primarily audience
funded show you can sign up for a membership
at Join Pakman Dotcom, Monday's bonus show
breaking all sorts of bonus show records,
the most watched and listened to bonus show
in history.
I talked about my run ins with a.
maskers during the vacation.
I talked about my deep nose swab or Schwab
as a former president would sometimes refer
to it.
My recommendation is first thing to do when
you sign up at join Pakman dot com.
Go to that Monday, April five bonus show.
The Matt Gates story is getting significantly
more interesting and significantly worse for
Matt Gates to catch you up.
A Republican congressman from Florida, Matt
Gates, is now in the middle of investigations
into very serious possible crimes, including
child sex trafficking.
Every time Gates speaks to try to plead his
innocence, he seems to present new derogatory
information about himself.
He presents new possible crimes that at least
some of us didn't even know he was under investigation
for.
And we have now learned, thanks to an investigation
from The New York Times, that Matt Gates sought
a preemptive blanket pardon from Donald Trump
at the end of Donald Trump's term.
Now, in retrospect, we know that at the time
that Matt Gates sought this pardon from Donald
Trump, Gates was already under investigation.
We don't know whether Gates knew that.
Was it Gates knowing he was under investigation
that caused him to seek the pardon from Donald
Trump?
Or was it Gates knowing he had committed crimes
and wasn't sure whether they would ever be
investigated?
That caused him to ask Donald Trump for a
pardon.
The New York Times reports that, quote, in
the final weeks of Trump's term and Gates
sought something in return for his unending
brownnosing support of Matt Gates.
That's my of Donald Trump.
That's my editorializing.
Gates privately asked the White House for
blanket preemptive pardons for himself and
for unidentified congressional allies for
any crimes they may have committed.
Around this time.
Gates was publicly calling for broad pardons
from Trump to thwart what he termed the, quote,
bloodlust of their political opponents.
Justice Department investigators had begun
questioning Gates associates about his conduct,
including whether he had a sexual relationship
with a 17 year old which violated child sex
trafficking laws in an inquiry that grew out
of the case of an indicted associate in Florida.
Now, here's the key line.
As I mentioned, it is unclear whether Gates
or the White House knew at the time that Gates
was under such an investigation.
It is unclear who else Gates wanted pardons
for.
He didn't tell the White House he was under
investigation.
Whether or not he knew it remains a question.
But according to The New York Times, White
House White House lawyers and officials viewed
the request for a preemptive pardon as a nonstarter
that would set a bad precedent.
The latest idea is when Gates asked for a
pardon for himself and others, the and others
might have been a way to camouflage his own
criminality.
In other words, if I know that I have committed
certain crimes or may be under investigation
for certain crimes, but I don't want to call
attention to that, I could go to Trump and
say, sir, you know, as as he claims people
do myself and a group of my colleagues are
all going to be persecuted for being a supporter
of yours, pardon all of us.
And you frame it as a preemptive protection
from like political prosecutions, knowing
that really the reason you want the pardon
is because you may have broken child sex child
sex trafficking laws and maybe you even know
that you're under investigation.
It's certainly an idea, and that is what some
Trump associates are speculating went on.
Now, ultimately, Matt Gates didn't get it.
As I told you, people around Donald Trump
thought that a preemptive blanket pardon for
Matt Gates would not be a good look.
And it was not something that Donald Trump
ultimately granted.
So there's a few different layers to this.
Obviously, there's the superficial layer of,
you know, asking for pardons in advance does
not project innocence.
That's someone with a guilty mind.
And of course, that's true.
The counter would be from the right that if
you're anticipating bogus political charges,
you would look for a blanket pardon as protection,
not because, you know, you committed a crime,
but because you anticipate that people from
the other political party are going to come
after you.
That's just an argument, right?
Both sides.
A talking point, and it sort of becomes just
an argument about the talking point, the bigger
picture here is it certainly seems as though
Matt Gates must be heading to a massive historic
downfall of epic proportions based on what
continues to be learned every single day.
You know, he goes on Tucker Carlson to clear
his name.
He further incriminates himself.
He says, my travel records will exonerate
me.
They raise even more questions.
Now we learn he was looking for a preemptive
pardon at every opportunity.
It seems to get worse.
And logic would point to this guy's got to
be going down, but maybe not.
Quite frankly, I think it is almost as likely
that this guy has a shot at being a prominent
Republican who knows presidential nominee
with the modern Republican Party.
You can never really tell what they will punish
versus what they will reward.
And although clearly all signs continue to
point to Gates is in a hell of a massive trouble
here.
How on earth does he get out of this one?
At the same time?
This is the Republican Party that we're dealing
with and they are very quick to demand consequences
for those on the left, but not for those on
the right.
This is an area where this is almost like
a critique of the of the Democratic Party,
sometimes the Democratic Party, in order to
show how they don't care who's doing the wrongdoing.
The Democratic Party has sometimes been too
quick to demand punishment for those on the
Democratic side in order to show how not biased
they are.
Arguably, the Al Franken situation is such
an example.
So Gates might end up never being heard from
again and resigning in shame or losing reelection,
going to prison.
Who the hell knows?
Or Gates might end up as the vice presidential
nominee in 2024?
Nothing would surprise me at this point
in time.